benim gz çık örünce cfar okuluna
YouTube'un en büyük coğraf kanalına
Hepiniz hoş geldiniz 39 günde tyt
coğrafya kampımız başlıyor Bu kamp full
kamptan sona bütün coğrafyayı
öğreneceğiz öğrenirken analizli bir
şekilde öğreneceğiz OGM materyaldeki
soruların analizleriyle öğreneceğiz
konunun en önemli noktalarının nereleri
olduğunu soruların genelde sorulduğunda
nereden geldiğini bütün hepsinin
analizlerini size vereceğim konuları
öğrenirken bilerek doğru yolda
ilerleyerek öğreneceksin bu kamp aynı
zamanda 9 sınıf ve 10 sınıf kampı dır Az
sonra neden öyle olduğunu kitabın
düzeninin nasıl ilerlediğini Aslında bu
kampla beraber bu kitapla beraber üçü
bir arada bir set Aldığını da göstermiş
olacağım sana ben hazırım Çok Fazla
uzatmayayım kalemimi alayım ben hazırım
Sen de beğen tuşuna basıp şurada abone
olduysan sen de hazırsan o zaman ne
diyoruz Yunus hocayla bir defa öğren bir
daha asla unutma gel şu tyt coğrafya'nın
canını okuyayım geldik şimdi tyt
coğrafyada Bugün ilk konumuz doğa ve
insan doğa ve insan konusuna başlamadan
önce bu konunun ne kadar önemli olduğunu
sana şöyle bir hatırlatayım neden
hatırlatayım sana Bakın şimdi doğa ve
insan konusu o kadar önemli bir konu ki
Coğrafyadan eskiden daha fazla soru
geliyordu 2017'den önce çok fazla soru
geliyordu o çok fazla sorunun geldiği
yıllarda her sene bir tane istisnasız
Sadece 2016'da yoktu istisnasız her sene
Coğrafyadan doğa ve insan konusundan
soru geliyordu Özellikle bu çok önemli
bir konudur gençler Çünkü coğrafyanın ne
demek olduğunu anlayacaksın bu konuda e
o yüzden bir coğrafya öğretmeni de ne
yapıyor geliyor sana sorularda ilk
olarak bunu sormak istiyor Sen
coğrafyayı anlamış mısın anlamamış mısın
coğrafyanın alt dalları nelerdir Bunu
bilmeni istiyor o yüzden geçmiş yıllarda
her sene bir soru soruluyordu Peki sınav
sistemi 2017'de değiştikten sonra ne
oldu bakalım şurada coğrafyanın alt
dallarına bakın 2018'de bir soru çıktı
2019'da bir soru çıktı iki yıl ard arda
bir soru çıkmadı 2022'de bir soru çıktı
bu sene 2000 Bir önceki sene yani
geçtiğimiz sınavda 2023'te bir soru
çıkmadı bakın coğrafyanın alt dalları
çok çok değerlidir bu konu şu an
işleyeceğimiz konu sana büyük bir
ihtimalle bir net kazandırma ihtimali
yüksektir en önem verdiğim konular bir
tanesidir sorularda denemelerde de
karşına çok fazla çıkacak aynı zamanda 9
sınıf olarak izliyorsan 9 sınıf olarak
da öğretmenim buradan sana çok fazla
soru soracaktır bu konu bizim temel
konularımız bir tanesidir bu konuyu
dikkatli dinleyeceksin merak etme
sorunun nereden nasıl sorulacağını da
Göstereceğim sana Evet gelin şimdi o
zaman dersimize geçelim konunun önemini
kavradığını düşünüyorum bugün kampımız
tyt coğrafya kampımız birinci günündeyiz
9 sınıf kampımız da birinci günündeyiz
gençler bakın Biz kitaplarımızı
oluştururken Ben Kitaplarımı
oluştururken yine ayt'de de öyle yaptım
bu kitapları sınıf sıralamasına göre
yapıyorum ben ne demek 9 sınıf Tamam 9
sınıf bakın tyt 9 sınıf sıralaması var
burada aynı MEB'in kazanımında sıralama
bu sonra 10 sınıf sıralaması var E tyt
dediğimiz şey 9 sınıf ve 10 sınıftan
oluşmuyor mu zaten ama ne yapıyorlar
biliyor musunuz 9 sınıfı sizi ayrı
satmak için 10 sınıfı ayrı satmak için
sonra bir de tyt kitabı satmak için tyt
kitabındaki konuları şöyle bir
karıştırıyorlar karıştırıyorlar sen tyt
kitabını ayrı bir şey sanıyorsun 9 10
sınıf kitabını ayrı bir şey sanıyorsun
Hayır aynı şey şeyler o yüzden bu
karışıklığı ortadan çıkartmak için ne
yaptık biz bakın Bu kitabın üstünde ne
yazıyor üçü bir arada kitap 9 sınıf
geliyorsun Al sana 9 sınıf aynı
okulundaki sıralama 9 sınıfı
öğreniyorsun 10 sınıfı öğreniyorsun E
bunların ikisinin toplamı da zaten
tyt'ye oluşturuyor O yüzden bu kampı tyt
öğrencileri takip edecek 9 sınıf
öğrencileri için bu kamp 10 sınıf
öğrencileri için de bu kampı
ilerleyeceğiz hemen Şu aşağıda
görüyorsunuz 9 sınıf coğrafya kampı 1
yazıyor yağ 9 sınıf coğrafya kampı 2
yazacak orada 3 yazacak sonra 10 sınıfa
geçtiğimizde Ben onu 10 sınıf olarak da
değiştireceğim tamam buradaki mantığı
öğrendik gelin şimdi ilk konumuz bugünkü
konumuz şu 1ci bölümü bitireceğiz doğal
sistemlerdeki birinci bölüm Doğa insan
ve coğrafyayı bitireceğiz bu konunun
neden önemli olduğunu az önce öğrendin
Niye sana gösteriyorum önemli olduğunu
Çünkü bu konuyu dinlerken daha dikkatli
dinlemen lazım dünyanın şekli ve
hareketlerinde mesela aynı şeyi
söylemeyeceğim sana ama bu konuda bu
konuya çok dikkat edeceksin geldim şimdi
belki sen ilk videoyu izlememişsinizdir
videosu vardı coğrafya nasıl çalışılır
hangi konulara nasıl çalışmam lazım
orada göstermiştim sana tekrar
uyarıyorum seni ve bir daha uyarmaya
Merak etmeyin bu bu uyarıları çok
yapıyorum Biliyorum Bir daha uyarmam
çalışacağım Dünya haritasını bilmiyorsan
bu kamptan ilerleyemezsin ilk önce dünya
haritası kampını izle şuraya bırakıyorum
yukarı dünya artas kampını izle hazır
bulunuşluğu tamamla yani çarpım tablosu
O bizim için Çarpım tablosunu öğrendin
hazırsın ben sana konuları anlatırken
Dünya haritasını biliyormuş gibi
anlatacağım Anlaştık mı sana çarpım
tablosunu tekrar anlatamam O zaman gelin
hızlı bir şekilde dersimize başlayalım
bir derse başlarken ilk önce o dersin
size tanımı verilir değil mi Coğrafya
nedir diye size Sorulur öğretmen gelir
sınıfa Coğrafya nedir Siz de o tanımı
ezberlersin ezberlemeye tanımları Ama bu
tanımın iki tane temel noktası var Bunu
bilmen lazım Coğrafya nedir Coğrafya
sana sorulsa Coğrafya nedir Bak bir
tarafa her zaman bunu unutma bu çok
değerli bir tarafa insanı koyacaksın bir
tarafa doğayı koyacaksın Bu o kadar
önemli ki bu tanıma ezberlemek değil bu
önemli bir taraf İnsan bir tarafta Doğa
bunu bildiğin zaman coğrafyayı çözmüş
oluyorsun Niye Çünkü coğrafya doğa ve
insanın karşılıklı etkileşimini
inceleyen bilim dalı yani Bizim
karşımızda iki tane kavram var bir
doğayı bileceğiz Bir de insanı bilip
bunların etkileşimini göreceğiz bakın
bugün bütün derste öğreneceklerimiz
Sadece bu iki kelime üzerinden gidecek
biliyor musunuz neden bakın doğal doğal
çevre bakın beşeri çevre görüyor musunuz
sonra diyeceğiz ki Doğa insan bunun
etkileşimi diyeceğiz görüyor musunuz son
son coğrafyayı alt dallarına ayıracağız
bakın ikiye ayırıyoruz fiziki doğal
coğrafya beşeri coğrafya doğal beşeri
insan demiştik ya işte o ayrım o kadar
önemli ki senu coğrafya denildiğinde
doğa ve insan diye biliyorsan Tamamdır
Sen coğrafyanın temelini kafanda
rahatlıkla oturtacak sın Şimdi gelelim
biz o zaman doğa kısmında Tamam bir Doğa
var Bir de insan var Doğa kısmına
bakalım Doğa kısmını oluşturan bazı
ortamlar var doğal çevreler var Bunun
içerisinde insan katkısı yok demek
istiyor Bak burada soru bize nasıl
soruluyor biliyor musun sorunun zorluk
kısmı Neresi sana desem ki dağlar beşeri
çevre midir Yani insan çevresi midir
beşeri Az sonra kodlayaz insan mıdır
desem Doğa mıdır desem doğadır dersin E
çünkü dağlar ovalar platolar ama sana
gelip Litosfer desem bilemiyorsun sana
atmosfer desem bilemiyorsun buradaki
değerli olan kavramlar İşte bunlar Doğal
ortam dediğimiz muhteşem dörtlü diye
çıkacak bu karşına muhteşem dörtlü
dediğimiz bu doğal ortamları bilmen
lazım Ne Bunlar bunların zorluk
kısımlarını kodlayaz seninle merak etme
Litosfer Litosfer litos Litosfer
Litosfer demek yok buna Litosfer
demiyordu buna Ne diyorduk Litosfer toz
toz var orada toz tozlar nasıl oluşuyor
alıyoruz elimize Balyoz umuzu kayaya
vuruyoruz taşlara vuruyoruz o taş
kırıldığında tozlara dönüşüyordu
Litosfer kayaların parçalanmasıyla
taşların parçalanmasıyla oluşmuş yani
Litosfer litos taş hocam taş küre
diyeceksin buna taş küre ve sana
sorularda ne soracak diyecek ki
aşağıdakilerden Hang hangisi Litosfer
içerisindedir işte sana akarsu göl dağ
diyecek Hah diyeceksin litos taş hocam
yer küreyle Yeryüzüyle taşlarla yer
kabuğu ile alakalı bir şey diyeceksin
buna Demek ki Litosfer dediğimizde
aklına taşküre gelecek dağ ova plato
bütün bu yeryüzü şekillerini
düşüneceksin burada işin zorluğu nerede
taşküre kavramında değil taş kü den
biliniyor burada işin zorluğu litosferi
bilmekte onu da ne yapıyoruz kodluyoruz
bu kanalın ismi ne coğrafyanın kodları O
yüzden ben sana elimde elimden
geldiğince elimden geldiğince değil
herhalde kodlamadım kavram bir tane iki
tanedir bütün böyle yabancı kavramları
baştan sona kodlayayım sana kodlamalar
başta saçma gelebilir hiç merak etme
gençler beni Şimdi siz çoğunuz
tanıyorsunuz artık 760.000 aboneye
ulaştık ama tanımayan ilk defa takip
edenler vardır bir defa söyleyeceğim
onlara bir daha söyleyince Merak etmeyin
ben kodlamalarla ders anlatıyorum
coğrafyanın kodları bu kanalın ismi Bak
ben bütün her şeyi kodlamak istiyorum
kodluyorum ki senin üzerine bir yük
binmesin sen o üzerine binecek yükü
kendin ezberlemekle uğraşma ben sana
bunun yöntemini hafıza teknikleriyle
göstereyim bu şekilde Öğren Sen de yorum
yapma gücünü geliştir bu derste soru
bankamız bizim Eylül'de çıkacak Eylül'de
de aynı bu şekilde soru çözüm kampı
yapacağız soru çözüm kampında O
kodlamaları ne kadar çok işe yaradığını
da Göstereceğim sana soru çözerken
geldim diğerine atmosfer hava küre E
hocam havayla alakalı Tamam atmosferi
biliyorsun herhalde diğeri en önemlisi
Burası sürekli karşımıza çıkıyor hidro
hidro H2 H2O diyeceksin buna H2O H2O
diyeceksin şurada H2O yu nasıl yazıyoruz
Ben açık açıkçası Eee kimya dersi meskem
kimyaya buradan Mesut hocam meskem kimya
H2O yu nasıl yazmam gerekiyor H H2O
şeklinde mi rezil olmayayım çok fazla
H2O hidro hidro H2O diyeceksin biri sana
hidro sorduğu gösterdiği zaman Hocam bu
H2O ile hocam suyla alakalı H2O su suyla
alakalı Göller dağlar akarsular şıklarda
verdi Göl dağ akarsu vesaire ha
hidrosferi koydum Bunu dağ dağ demedim
Az önce değil mi Göller Dağlar mı dedim
az önce pardon dağ ova dedi litosfere
Göller akarsular denizler okyanuslar
hidrosfere Anlaştık mı rüzgarlar
atmosfere Evet e Biyosfer biyoloji bitki
canlılar canlılarla alakalı Biyosfer
buraya da biyosferi koyacaksın şunu
söyleyeyim size böyle bir soru
çıkabiliyor Özellikle o geme materyalde
böyle bir soru gördüm Mesela şöyle
atmosfer diyelim şöyle bir tane daha
yuvarlak çizdim bunlar küreler Bu da
Litosfer Bir tane de hidrosfer çizdim
burada Biyosfer nerededir diyor Biyosfer
bunların kesiş iği noktadadır değil mi
Çünkü hepsinin ortak kesişim noktasında
Biyosfer var Böyle bir soru Görmüştüm
bunu da bilin Anlaştık mı buraya kadar
Tamam mıyız bunları öğrendik mi Bunlar
doğal ortamlardır muhteşem dörtlüyü bir
de beşeri ortamlar var yani beşeri ortam
insanla alakalı Beşer duydun mu Beşer
sürekli çıkacak senin karşına doğal
fiziki olacak insanın içerisinde
olduğunu gördün mü Beşer diyeceksin
beşer beşer şaşarda Gelecek aklına benim
hep öyle geliyor Beşir Beşer Beşir insan
böyle çalıştırıyorum evet Demek ki
beşeri ortam denildiğinde de böyle
insanı insanla alakalı olanlar
diyeceksin Bütün bunların Doğal ortamlar
beşeri ortamların hepsini topladığımızda
da ortaya coğrafi ortam çıkıyor şimdi
biz ne öğrendik şimdi Litosfer hidrosfer
atmosfer biyosferi öğrendik bunların
yabancıların Türkçe karşılıklarını ve
coğrafyadaki ortamları hangisinin
hangisine koyacağımızı öğrendik Tamam ne
öğrendik en baştan beri coğrafyayı Doğa
insan diye ayırdık ilk önce doğal
kısımların ne olduğunu insanın ne
olduğunu insanın etkisinin olduğu
yerlerin ne olduğunu gördük şimdi E bu
doğa ve insan K karşılıklı etkileşim
içerisinde olmuyor mu işte şimdi geldik
doğa ve insanın karşılıklı etkileşimine
gençler bakın Biz doğayı etkiliyor Doğa
da bizi etkiliyor aynı zamanda Doğa
doğayı da etkileyebiliyor işte sorularda
bize böyle sorma ihtimali var bu konunun
soru gelme ihtimalinin % 70'i
coğrafyanın alt dallarıyla Az sonra
göstereceğim sana oradan % 70'i 80'i
oradan gelecek Büyük bir ihtimalle eğer
gelirse soru gelirse bize Bunun yorum
sorusunu soracaklar yani ve Aşağıda
verilenlerden h hangisinde İnsan doğayı
etkilemiştir Aşağıda verilenlerden
hangisinde doğa insanı etkilemiştir gibi
sorulacak bize Bunun soru gelme ihtimali
olan kısmı Burası bunu yorumlamam
gerekiyor Aslında burasını soru
üzerinden gitmek çok daha güzel soruları
çözdükçe oturacak bir konu Burası soru
üzerinden gittiğinizde Siz o yorumlama
yeteneğini arttıracak Eylül'de soru
bankası üzerinden çözerken bununla
alakalı güzel sorular çözeceğiz şimdi
sana bir iki örnek göstereceğim şöyle
şöyle gösteriyorum mesela kendimiz
bulalım hangisi kimi nasıl etkilemiş
diye mesela şu şu şekilde süve kanalının
yapılması bak insan Süveyş kanalını
yapmış Biz doğayı etkilemiş İnsan doğayı
etkilemiş sanki soruymuş gibi çözmeye
çalışacağım burayı bak Rüzgar
santrallerinin kurulması e insan Rüzgar
santrali kuruyor e kurarken ne oluyor
İnsan doğayı etkiliyor bu tarafa geldim
Karadeniz'de evlerin ahşaptan yapılması
genelde en fazla
yorumlayıp yapılır diye bir soru kendine
Niye ben Karadeniz'de evi ahşaptan
yapıyorum kutuplara gittiğimde İglo
dediğimiz o evler vardı orada buzdan an
yapılan evler Niye ben niye buralarda
evleri böyle farklı yapıyorum Güneydoğu
Anadolu'da niye kerpiçten topraktan ev
yapıyorum E çünkü her tarafta Toprak var
E Toprak varsa ben evimi topraktan
yapıyorum E o zaman yani çevre Doğa beni
etkilemiş oluyor Doğa benim hangi evi
nasıl yapacağımı da etkiledi mi etkiledi
bak Erzurum Kars çevresinde büyükbaş
hayvancılığın yapılması niye Erzurum
Kars çevresinde büyükbaş hayvancılık
yapılıyor da daha İç Anadolu Bölgesinde
böyle biraz daha bozkırların olduğu
yerlerde küçükbaş hayvancılık yapılıyor
Çünkü Erzurum ve çevresinde çayırlar var
e çayırlar da büyükbaş hayvancılık için
çok uygun e çayırlar olduğu zaman sen de
orada büyükbaş hayvan bakıyorsun bak
dışarıdaki doğal çevre benim büyüteceğim
besleyeceğim hayvanı bile etkiledi mi
etkiledi Bozkır alanı İç Anadolu
bölgesindeyim Bozkır alanları ver her
tarafta küçük küçük çayırlar ilk barda
iş veriyorlar yazın sar arıyorlar küçük
küçük çayırlar Ben burada büyükbaş
hayvan bakamam doyamaz orada o zaman ne
yapacağım küçükbaş hayvanı besleyeceğim
ee bak dışarıdaki doğal çevre benim
hangi hayvanı besleyeceğim bile etkiledi
mi etkiledi dışarıdaki doğal çevre benim
nasıl bir giysi giyeceğimi bile etkiledi
mi etkiledi Evet bu örnekleri böyle
yorumlayacak tarlaların nadasa
bırakılması Nadas kavramı bizim için çok
değerli Şimdi hemen kenara bir yere
orada senin not defterin olsun Ben sana
önemli bilgiler verdiğimde o not
defterine kaydedecek soru çözümlerde o
not defterine önemli bilgiler vereceğim
sana kaydedecek Burada konu
anlatımlarında önemli kavramlar
vereceğim sana kayd edeceksin neden
Nadas kavramı tarım konusuyla AYT
konusuyla alakalı ama bizim tyt'de
karşımıza çıkıyor bu sene mesela nadası
değil nöbetle hekimi sordular biz de bir
soruda hem nadası hem nöbetleşe hekimi
öğrenmiştik mesela nöbetleşe Hekim çıktı
böyle konuları not alman lazım Nadas
susuz diyeceksin Nadas susuz tarım Yani
toprağı bir sene ekiyor Çiftçi ikinci
sene ekecek toprağı ama toprakta su yok
sulama imkanı da yok ekstansif tarım
yapıyor yani eski yöntemlerle modern
olmayan yöntemlerle bir tarım yapıyor
gelişmemiş bir ülke Çünkü burası Şimdi
ben toprağı sulayacağım e Yağmur da çok
fazla yok toprağa iklime bağımlılığım
çok fazla Benim e ne yapacağım O zaman
diyorum ki ya Bir seni ek miyim
toprağımı Bir sene ektim bir sene
ekmeğim su mineral biriksin orada Ondan
sonraki sene tekrar ekerim toprağı
nadasa bırakıyorum nadasa bırakmak Bu
bir sene boş bırakıyorsun doğru bir
uygulama değildir olmaması gereken bir
uygulamadır Türkiye'de Nadas alanları
Her geçen yıl azalmaktadır bu kötü bir
şey mi Bak Türkiye'de nad alanları Her
geçen yıl azalır Hayır güzel bir şey
Neden Çünkü kuru tarım Çünkü toprağı boş
bırakma azalıyor muu toprağı sulama
imkanları arttığı için toprağı Artık
insanlar boş bırakmıyor muu toprağı boş
bırakmamak gereki Nadas kötü bir
uygulamadır şimdi Gelelim asıl konumuza
bunun notunu al nadasın Ne olduğuyla
alakalı sürekli testlerde orada burada
karşımıza çıkar Bu kavram o kavramı
Senin senden istediğim güzel bir not
defterimiz olsun sürekli böyle önemli
noktaları oraya yazdıracağım sana nadası
yazdık mı Yazdık Peki hocam bununla Ne
alakası var tarlaların nadasa
bırakılması demiş nadasa niye
bırakıyorum ben tarlamı iklim kurak
olduğu için su olmadığı için yani doğa
insanı etkilemiş mi etkilemiş Tamam
mıyız buraya kadar doğanın Doğa yetkisi
ile alakalı da örneklerimiz var bizim
mesela akarsuların Vadi dev kazanı gibi
şekiller oluşturması Doğa Akarsu Akarsu
akıyor orada bir dev kazanı şekil 10
sınıfta öğreneceğiz bunları Vadi
oluşturuyor Vadi oluşturuyor Doğa doğayı
etkilemiş bununla alakalı en güzel şey
soru çözmek bu konuyu anlamanın en güzel
yöntemi şu kısmı anlamanın en güzel
yöntemi soru çözmektir soru Bankasını da
Eylül'de çözeceğiz OGM materyaldeki
soruları da çözmeyi unutmuyorsun senin
için OGM materyal çok çok önemli
Anlaştık mı geldik ikinci kısma asıl
önemli olan kısım Burası Çünkü sorunun
geldiği kısım Burası oluyor yani
coğrafyanın alt dalları an soru geliyor
bakın 2013'ten sonraki sorulara
bakmıştım hepsi coğrafyanın neredeyse
coğrafyanın alt dalıyla alakalı Yani
senin coğrafyanın alt Dalını bilmen
lazım asıl bizde son 5 yıldır ü tane
soru çıktı ya o ü soru da bununla
alakalıydı coğrafyanın alt dalı Ben
coğrafyayı ayıracak olsam kaça ayırırım
düşünün Ben coğrafyanın tanımını
yaparken size ne demiştim doğa ve insan
demiştim değil mi o zaman coğrafyayı
ayıracak olsam kaça ayıracağım ikiye
ayıracağım doğa ve insan olarak ikiye
ayıracağım Ama bunlar böyle çok basit
doğa ve insan diye ayırmak çok mantıklı
değil doğaya doğal çevre fiziki çevre
diyelim beşe insana insana da Ne
diyorduk Beşer Beşir diyorduk beşeri
coğrafya diyor coğrafyayı bu şekilde
ikiye ayıracağız şimdi buraya gelmeden
önce Şu üstteki kısımları da bir görelim
coğrafyanın tanımını vermiş burada
öğrenmiştik bir de coğrafyanın ilkeleri
diye bir şey var şimdi coğrafyanın
ilkelerini de görelim senin coğrafyanın
ilkelerinden kastımız her bilimin ilkesi
olduğu gibi bizim de belirli metotlar
mız var bu metotlardan en önemlisi
dağılış ilkesi basit beil mesela coğ
coğrafyada en değerli şey ben size ne
diyorum coğrafyada bak diyorum size Eğer
bu tyt kampına başlayacaksan AYT kampına
başlayacaksan gidip Çarpım tablosunu
öğren bizim çarpım tablomuz haritadır
diyor değil mi dünya haritalarını izle
diyorum sana dünya haritalarını
izlediğinde rahatlıkla anlıyorsun konuyu
Niye Çünkü coğrafyayı coğrafya yapan
dağılış ilkesi İşte bu yüzden harita
soruları sürekli çıkıyor bizim karşımıza
Bu yüzden ÖSYM haritaya dünya haritası
okuma becerisine Türkiye haritası okuma
becerisine önem veriyor yani dağılış
ilkesi İşte bu demek harita bir yer de
bir konuyu açıklarken Eğer ki bir
dağılış yapıyorsanız harita üzerinde bir
dağılım yapıyorsanız İşte bu bizim
dağılış ilkesine giriyor nedir bu
coğrafyadaki nerede sorusunun cevabıdır
yani bakıyoruz Mesela bir cümle
kuruyorum Ben sorulara sorularda çok
güzel örnekleri çözeceğiz bununla
alakalı cümle kuruyorum diyorum ki
Türkiye'deki küçükbaş hayvancılığın
koyun üretiminin yapıldığı yerler
Güneydoğu Anadolu İç Anadolu bölgesidir
ne yaptım bak bir dağılış yaptım işte bu
dağılışı yapıyorsam burada bir dağılış
ilkesi var Anlaştık mı Eğer ki bir
cümlede orada burada şurada nerede
sorusuna cevap varsa bu dağılış ilkesi
diğer bir ilke Aslında bu biliyorsunuz
Nedensellik ilkesi neden sonuç olacak
Burada yüksek basınç alanından dolayı
rüzgarlar oluşmuştur gibi Neden sonuç
ilişkisi bu basit Türkçede var bu Sizin
kafanızı karıştıran burada karşılıklı
ilgi bağlantı ilkesi karşılıklı ilgi ne
demek bu Mesela şöyle diyelim bakın
deprem olan bölgelerde yani fay hattının
geçtiği bölgeler deprem bölgeleri Niye
Çünkü bir kırık oluyor bir deprem
bölgesi oluyor sonra aynı zamanda
buradan dışarıya lavlar çıkıyor e burada
volkanik dağlar da oluyor şimdi biz şunu
söyleyebiliyoruz değil mi deprem
alanlarıyla volkanik sahalar birbiriyle
bağlantılıdır aynı zamanda o kırıktan
aşağıya sular Sızıyor aşağıda ısınıyor
sular yukarı çıkıyor sıcak sular oluyor
mesela Sıcak sularla beraber deprem
bölgeleri de bağlantılı Yani şunu
diyebiliyoruz Ben bir yere baktığımda
bir yerde fay hatları varsa bir yerde O
zaman o yerde deprem bölgesi olabilir o
yer aynı zamanda volkanik dağların
olduğu yer olabilir sıcak Sular da
olabilir sıcak sular deprem bölgeleri
volkanik dağlar Bunların hepsi
birbiriyle
bağlantılıdır işte bağlantı ilkesi budur
genç bununla alakalı da size böyle yorum
soruları çıkacaktır Ama asıl sorunun
geleceği yer burası mı Hayır biz Gelelim
asıl sorunun geleceği yere Az önce
ayırdık biz bunu beşeri coğrafya fiziki
coğrafya testlerde de soru bankalarında
da OGM materyalde de her tarafta seni
Zorlayacak olan kısım Burası burayla
alakalı sorular çözmen lazım buranın zor
kısmı neresi biliyor musunuz fiziki
coğrafya doğal çevreyle alakalı beşeri
coğrafya insanla alakalı gelin şöyle
beşeri coğrafyanın altına bir bakalım mı
Beşir insan şimdi nüfus coğrafyası nüfus
nüfus insanla alakalı bir şey insan
değil mi zaten kendisi nüfus O zaman ben
bunu getirip beşeri coğrafyanın altına
koyacağım bir örnekle göstereyim size
hidrografya hidro H2O öğrenmiştik
seninle e H2O su hidrografya H2 o's su
sular coğrafyası şimdi su coğrafyası
insanla mı alakalı Hayır insanın beşeri
coğrafyanın altına getirip koymayacaksın
o zaman bunu nereye fiziki Doğal
çevrenin altına koyacaksın bunu bunları
da ezberlemeye ceğin hangisini hangis
hangisinin altına koyacağını İlk önce
sen kendin öğreneceksin hidrografya H2O
su O zaman ben bunu doğal coğrafyanın
altına koyarım tarım coğrafyası tarım
insan yapıyor Bunu o zaman getirir
beşeri coğrafyanın altına koyar Anlaştık
mı Şimdi burada zor olan ne biliyor
musunuz beşeri coğrafyanın altındakileri
bilmek çok kolay nüfus coğrafyası bak
çok basit nüfusu inceliyor bu kadar
yerleşme e insanların yerleşme
yerleşmelerini inceliyor insanla mı
alakalı Evet o zaman beşeri coğrafyanın
altına tarım coğrafyası insanla mı
alakalı o zaman beşeri coğrafyanın
altına sanayiyi insan yapıyor ulaşımı
Turizm coğrafyasını siyasi coğrafya
enerji coğrafyası Bunlar insanla alakalı
insan yapıyor O zaman beşeri coğrafyanın
altına bunları koymak çok basit işin zor
olan kısmı bu tarafta Bunlar coğrafyanın
alt dalları bak fiziki coğrafya la
alakalı olan kısım zor burada çok kavram
var Bunları kodlayaz hiç merak etme
sorularda en kolay yapacağım Bunlar
olacak geldik ilk olarak
hidrografyanın değil ilk olarak şurada
Pardon bir dakika Burası karıştı şöyle
Jeomorfoloji
Jeomorfoloji biri bana Jeomorfoloji
dediğin zaman nasıl yapıyor Biz bunu jeo
jeo yer jeo yer jeo yer jeo yer artık
Eskiden dinlememişsin kampları artık Siz
bunu çok iyi biliyorsunuzdur şöyle atla
10 saniye atlamalı yapın Çünkü ilk defa
dinleyenler için yapmam lazım jeo joo J
jer jeo j j jer joo jer jer jer jer jeer
saçmalamıyor beyninde kalacak bu jer jer
jeer jeer jeer jer Az sonra bir kodlama
için hazırlık da yaptım size bir tane
limon da var bekleyin durun Siz j o yer
jeo yer jeo yer J yer J yer J yer j yer
jeo yer Jeomorfoloji bak
Jeomorfoloji
Jeomorfoloji morfo motif morfo modifiye
şekil şekil demek modifiye motif şekil
Jeomorfoloji yer şekli bilme dağlar
ovalar platolar gibi şeyleri duyduğunda
yer şekilleri ile alakalı bilgileri
duyduğunda onu getirip jeomorfolojiye
koyacaksın Anlaştık mı Bak bu
coğrafyanın alt dalı tamam mı yer şekil
bu coğrafyanın alt dalı Bir de şurada
bakın siyahla çizdiğimiz bir yerler var
isim ini koyduğumuz Bunlar coğrafyaya
yardımcı bilimler yardımcı bilimler bir
Dursun ilk önce bir coğrafyanın alt
dallarını öğrenelim yardımcı bilimin ne
olduğunu görürüz diğer tarafa biyo
coğrafya Neyi inceleyebilir e biob
biyoloji bitki canlılar coğrafyası
canlıları incele bu basit diğeri
Klimatoloji Bak yanlış yazmışlar bunu
buraya Vallahi yanlış yazmışlar Bak
Klimatoloji diye bir şey yok Klimatoloji
diye bir şey yok iklim atol diye bir şey
var ikilim
matojelic alt dalı klimadan da aklınıza
gelebilir iklimi oluşturuyor yani iklimi
değiştiriyor sıcaksa soğuk yapıyor
hidrografya Bak az önce öğrenmiştik
nasıl karşımıza çıktı H2O H2O hidro su
hocam o zaman suları inceleyen
coğrafyanın alt dalı da hidrograf geldik
diğerine coğrafyanın alt dallarını ilk
önce öğrenelim sonra yardımcı bilimlere
bakarız geldik sonuncuya
kartografya kartografya Bir coğrafya
öğretmeni olarak bir coğrafya öğretmeni
olarak sen değerli öğrencime Düşünsenize
öğretmen hergen genelde coğrafya
öğretmenleri ne yapar ilk ilk sın sınıfa
böyle girdiklerinde ilk önce bir harita
ödevleri verir herkese değil mi Ben de
bir coğrafya öğretmeni olarak tabii
artık benim okulum Burası coğrafyanın
kodları Okulu Burası Okuldan ayrıldım
istifa ettim artık okulda çalışmıyorum
biliyorsunuz artık benim okulum Burası
ve okulumun ilk mezunları 2024 Tayfa
sizlersiniz Neden Çünkü bu kanalı 2020
yılında kurdum ben o zaman 9 sınıf
öğrencilerimi almaya başlamıştım o
aldığım 9 sınıf öğrencileri Ben 9
sınıflara ilk video yapmaya başlamıştım
o aldığım 9lar 10 oldu 11 oldu bugün siz
2024 Tayfa benim kanalımın ilk mezunları
olacaksınız ve size ödev vermeden geçer
miyim asla öyle öyle bir ayıp etmem ödev
vereceğim size Ne diyordum kartona
harita Çizeceksin harita çizme ödevi
vereceğim size ama şimdi harita çizersen
Çizeceksin ben de geleceğim şimdi arkaya
bir hala yapamadım bir iki eklenti daha
yapacağım oralara hala şekillendir
demedim diyeceğim ki aslında Bak şöyle
bir harita çizdik buraya aslında şu
harita üzerinden yapalım şimdi siz böyle
bir kağıda harita çizsin kağıda harita
çizsin olur mu Olmaz yır atılır kötü
görülür olmaz değil mi Ama siz kartona
harita çizersen şurada olduğu gibi tabii
o karton değil ahşaplar geç orasını geç
şöyle bir kartona harita çizersen hiçbir
şey olmaz düşmez oraya yapıştırabiliriz
değil mi o zaman haritalarımız neye
çiziyoruz şöyle bir dakika haritalarımız
neye çiziyoruz haritalarımız kartona
çiziyoruz hocam Ne anlatıyorsun sabahtan
beri ya
kartografya
kartografya karton getirdi mi aklına Bak
kar toğraf karton kartonu ne yapmıştık
hocam harita çizmiştik harita bil
gençler kart coğrafya çok sorularda çok
kafamızı karıştırıyor 2022'de çıkmış
soruda birçok öğrencinin kafasını
karıştırmıştı tek de yapanlar oldu ama
bu kodlama sayesinde kar toğraf harita
çizimiyle ilgileniyor kar toğraf
unutmuyorsun kar toğraf şöyle de unutma
kar toğraf Sonuçta biz doğayı doğayı
aktarıyoruz ya haritaya doğayla alakalı
bir şey beşeri coğrafyanın alt dalında
değil fiziki coğrafyanın alt dalındadır
kafanızı karıştıracak bir soru çıkabilir
buradan dikkat edin bakın Biz şimdi
neleri öğrendik biyocoğrafya
jeomorfoloji Klimatoloji hidrografya
kartografya Bunlar fiziki coğrafyanın
alt dalları Ama bu fiziki coğrafyanın
alt dallarının Bir de yardım yardım
aldığı bilimler var Şöyle mesela
hidrografya bak hidrografyanın şimdi
hidrografya coğrafyanın alt dalı fiziki
coğrafyanın alt dalı ama şimdi
hidrografya gidip ne bileyim gölleri
inceleyebilir mi bir coğrafyacı Hayır
gölleri başka biri inceler O başka bir
bilimdir Biz ondan faydalanırız işte
hidrografya bir coğrafyacı olarak ben
coğrafyanın alt balığında hidrografya da
çalışma yapıyorsam giderim Şuradaki
bilimler den yardım alırım işte bunlar
da bizim yardımcı bilimlerimi bu
yardımcı bilimler bize soruluyor nedir
hidroloji bak çok basit hidro H2O loji
H2O su loji bilim su bilmi Tamam e su
bilmi hidrografyanın altında olur bu
kolaydı çünkü
hidroyapı olacak onlar için benim bile
Şu an biraz rahatsız oldum limnoloji
denildiğinde bize gitmişim Ben bir gölün
kenarına bu kodlama yeni Eskiden başka
şekilde anlatıyordum bunu güzel bir
kodlama bulduk buna şöyle geldim gölün
kenarına gitmişim Nasrettin hocayım Ben
Nasrettin hocayım gölün kenarına
gitmişim Göle limon sıkıyorum Göle Şu an
ne yapıyorum Göle Göle limon sıkıyorum
ha bu da var şöyle su Göle limon
sıkıyorum şöyle limon sıkıyorum Göle Sen
de gelip bana soruyorsun Hoca hoca ne
yapıyorsun Göl hiç ekşir mi diyorsun
bana Hoca hoca ne yapıyorsun diyorsun
bana Ben de diyorum görmüyor musun Göle
limon sıkıyorum sen de diyorsun ki
oradan E hocam yani Göle limon sıkıyor
da Göl ekşir mi Ben diyorum ki ya
ekşirse Bayağı da bir ekşiyi ya ekşirse
şimdi bak başa gelelim hikayenin başına
limnoloji limnoloji Limona benziyor
Yunus hoca Göle limon sıkıyordu nereye
sıkıyordu Göle limon sıkıyordu Nasrettin
Hoca da Göle maya çalmaya çalışmıyor
muydu Ben de Göle limon sıkıyorum Göl
bilimidir Anlaştık mı Bunu da öğrendik
mi Evet
oseonografya
oseonografya Okyanus bilmi böyle
diyeceksin testte soruyu çözerken Aynı
bu sesim yankılanacak beyninde
oseonografya okyanus bilmi oseonografya
okyanus bilmi o'an da İngilizcesi iyi
olanlar Oradan da getirebilir aklına
benim kötü olduğu için buna böyle bir
kodlama yapt potamoloji pota
düşüneceksin burada potayı düşün bunu
hayal etmek zorundayız artık potayı
düşün şöyle potaların altında fileler
var değil mi bağladık o fileyi şöyle
güzel bir bağladık hayal et gözünde Can
falandır bağladık getiriyorum böyle bir
akarsuyun ağzında akarsuda balık tutmaya
çalışıyorum potla beraber akarsuyun
ağzında getiriyorum Böyle balık
tutuyorum potamoloji hemen o aklına
gelecek akarsuyun ağzında Yunus hoca
balık tutmaya çalışıyordu potla Akarsu
bilme
hidrojeoloji son yıllarda Israrla bunu
soruyorlar OGM materyalde ben baktım
bazı şıklarda özellikle hidrojeoloji
soruyor bak hidro H2O su jeo jeo yer jeo
yer jeo yer jeo yer jeo yer jeo yer jeo
yer hidro jeo hidro su jeo yoji birim
yer su bilim yeraltı suları bilmi
hidrojeoloji sana burada soruyu nasıl
sorar biliyor musun Aşağıda verilen
yardımcı bilim dallarından hangisi
hidrografyanın yardım aldığı bilim
dallarından bir tanesi değildir diye
sorar işte Senin buradaki yabancı
kavramların hepsini bilmen lazım
soruları bunları bildiğinde
çözebileceğiniz zaman iki gün sonra
unutuyorsun İki gün sonra unutmasan Bir
ay sonra unutuyorsun sana bir ay sonra
sen bu konuyu öğrendiğinde biri
limnoloji dese O nereden hatırlayacaksın
onu milyonlarca ders öğreniyorsun o
milyonlarca dste binlerce binlerce ders
ters söyledim binlerce ders öğreniyorsun
o binlerce derste milyonlarca kavram
öğreniyorsun hangi bir aklında kalacak
kalmaz Ama böyle çalışırsan aklında
kalacak biyocoğrafya hangilerinden
yararlanabilir e bakın biyoloji bitki
Tamam mantıklı e Botanik bitkiyle
alakalı Tamam biyoloji canlı Pardon
bitki dedim orada zooloji zu hayvan
oradan gele debir aklınıza Bunlar
biyoloji Bunlar basit bunları bildiğiniz
şeyler gelelim Jeomorfoloji jeo yer jeo
yer jeo yer jeo yer Jeomorfoloji yer
şekilleri bilmey jeoloji jeo yer yer
bilme Jeofizik yer fiziği Tamam
jeomorfolojinin bunlarla bunlardan
yardım alması gayet normal geldik ha de
öğrenemeyeceğiniz
hiç deli Pedro deli Pedro deli Pedro
deli Pedro diye biri gerçekten var Rus
Çarı gerçekten deli Pedro diye biri var
araştırın deli Pedro yazın bakalım Rus
Çarı gerçekten var Peki bu deli Pedro
niye delirmiş biliyor musunuz çocukken
birisi almış kafasına kafasına taş atmış
şöyle bir dakika taş bulacaktım daha
gerçekçi olsun diye bulamadım kafasına
biri almış deli Pedro pedro'nun kafasına
taş atmış niye delirmiş kafasına taş
yediği için delirmiş deli Pedro niye
delirdi kafasına taş yediği için pedr
grafi Pedro deli Pedro diyeceksin Pedro
Pedro yok deli Pedro niye taştan dolayı
taş bilimidir Tamam diğeri Pedoloji
pedol pedal pedal pedal a o bisiklet
pedalları var ya Hiçbir zaman hiç
topraksız kalmaz her zaman o toprak
oraya gelir yapışır Bir de suyu gördü mü
çamurlaşır Hemen hep çamurdur hep
Topraklı dır o pedallar Pedoloji pedal
pedallar hep Topraklı dır gözünün önüne
o pedalları getir Topraklı pedalları
getir Anlaştık mı Pedoloji yi de
öğrendik mi petrografi deli Pedro
limnoloji Göle limon sıkıyordu O da
güzel Tamam Klimatoloji Klimatoloji
iklim klima iklimle alakalı
meteorolojiden yararlan anıyor
meteoroloji meteorolojiden alınan Hava
durumuna göre yarın hava yağmurlu olacak
kısa süreli hava olaylarını meteoroloji
işliyor Klimatoloji uzun süreli hava
olayları meteorolojiden ve Fizikten
yararlanıyor burayı anlayabiliriz
kartografi harita çizeceğiz matematik
lazım bana geometri lazım bana astronomi
lazım Bunları bildiğiniz için bunları
tek tek Açıklamama gerek yok geldik en
zor kısmı burasıydı sorunun geleceği
kısmı da burasıydı çünkü geçmiş yıllarda
çıkmış 8 9 10 soru falan çıkmış hepsi
buradan çıkmış hepsi buradan çok basit
sorular Ama neye göre basit yabancı
kavramı biliyorsan basit kartografyaya
limnoloji jeomorfolojiye biliyorsan
basit bu kavramları bildiğinde gelecek
derslerde de bunlar çok işine yarayacak
hiç merak etme Jeomorfoloji hidrografi
hidro Hidroelektrik santral mesela
sürekli sürekli karşına çıkacak
kavramlar Bunlar Evet Peki hocam biz bu
kadar ders öğreneceğiz coğrafya dersi
öğreneceğiz değil mi ya bu coğrafya
benim ne işime yarayacak Hani o en temel
kısma geldik Hani diyorsun ya hocam
geliyorsun böyle hocam ya ben bu
matematiği Öğreneceğim ama bu matematik
benim ne işime yarayacak ya ben bu
tarihi öğreniyorum da bu tarih benim ne
işime yarayacak benim dersime o lafı
kullanamazsın niye kullanamazsın bu
coğrafyayı öğreneceğim de bu coğrafya
benim ne işime yarayacak diyemezsin
dışarı kafanı çıkardığın andan itibaren
her taraf coğrafya dersiyle alakal her
taraf ekonomisinden tutun siyasetine
kadar doğal afetine kadar her şey
Coğrafyayla alakal doğal afetler
yaşıyoruz çok ciddi doğal afetleri
yaşıyoruz bu ciddi doğal afetlerin çok
ciddi kayıplarını görüyoruz Coğrafyayla
coğrafya bilmediğimizden kaynaklanıyor
bu ekonomimize bakıyoruz tarıma
bakıyoruz hayvancılığı öğreniyoruz AYT
konusu bu Tarım Hayvancılık vesaire
ihracatı ithalatı öğreniyoruz
ekonomimizi öğreniyoruz enflasyonu
öğreniyor şu an hayatının tam Odak
noktasında olan ekonomi coğrafyasını
Coğrafya dersinde öğreniyorsun tarımı
madenleri öğreniyorsun gerçekten
ülkemizde maden nerelerde var
çıkartılıyor mu
çıkartılamadı ne satıyoruz tarım
üretimimiz ne durumda hayvancılık hayvan
üretiyor muyuz bakın Bütün bunların
hepsini doğal afetlerinden tutun
ekonomiye kadar hepsini Coğrafyayla Hani
dışarıdaki rüzgar Akarsu vesaire bunları
demiyorum Hani oradaki Rüzgar niye esti
Yağmur nasıl yağıyor bütün bunları
geçtim direkt hayatının tam Odak
noktasında ekonomi bile Coğrafyayla
alakalı niye coğrafya dersi bu ülkede
sevilmiyor niye coğrafya dersi
müfredattan ısrarla kaldırılmaya
çalışılıyor Çünkü hayatın tam Odak
noktasında olan bir dersim diğer dersler
gibi öyle biraz daha farklı Hani diyor
öğretmenlere diyorsunuz ya niye Hocam
biz bunu hayatın neresinde göreceğiz
dediğiniz noktada değiliz Biz Biz
hayatın tam orta noktasındayız
coğrafyayı öğrendiğinde hayatı öğrenmiş
oluyorsun daha anlamlı her şeyi
yorumlayabilir hayatta ekonomide cebinde
Niye paran olmadığını bile
yorumlayabilen işte coğrafya dersi
istenmiyor coğrafya dersi müfredattan
olabildiğine kaldırılmaya çalışılıyor
yok edilmeye Ç çalışılıyor Niye Çünkü
coğrafi dersi bilen birisi doğal afet
yaşandığında bunun Neden yaşandığını
biliyor Neden ölümlerin çok fazla
olduğunu biliyor cebindeki paranın niye
az olduğunu da biliyor tarım üretiminin
tarım ürünlerinin niye pahalı olduğunu
da biliyor ekonomi hakkında yorum da
yapabiliyor Enflasyonun ne demek
olduğunu da biliyor madenlerin çıkıp
çıkmadığını da biliyor Bütün her şeyin
yorumunu yapabiliyor yani Coğrafya
biliminin önemi kısmında Sana önemli
şeyler anlattım burada işte coğrafya Bu
yüzden önemli coğrafya Bu yüzden
kaldırılıyor müfredattan coğrafyayı
bilmeniz Bu yüzden is denmiyor coğrafya
İyi ki coğrafyacı olmuşum diyor çünkü
coğrafya direkt hayatın kendisini
anlatıyor tarımı işliyorum hayvancılığı
işliyorum doğal afetleri işliyorum
direkt hayatın kendisini işliyorum % 180
derslerimin içeriğinde direkt hayatın
kendisini işliyorum Evet coğrafya Bu
yüzden önemli işte bu da dersimiz
coğrafyanın niye önemli olduğunun
dersini işledik Şimdi geldik coğrafya
bilmenin tarihi gelişimine şimdi tamam
coğrafya dersini öğrendik Bu Coğrafya
biliminin tarihi gelişimi çok önemli mi
testlerde vesaire karşınıza çıkacak ama
böyle geçmiş yıllarda bununla alakalı
sorular ız var mı Yok gelme ihtimali var
mı çok çok düşük ama biz yine burada püf
noktalarıyla beraber bunu öğreneceğiz
soru gelirse nasıl gelir Bunu da bakalım
şimdi her bilimde olduğu gibi
coğrafyanın da bir tarihi gelişimi var
hani geçmişte Şuradaki isimlerine bakar
mısınız Tales Aristoteles herodot bütün
bütün bilimlerin zaten temelinde bunlar
var E tabii Bunlar yaptığı bilimlerde
Biz de baktığımızda A bak coğrafyada
yapmış diyoruz coğrafyaya da alıyoruz
bunları coğrafyayı da çeşitli bölümlere
ayırıyoruz Geçmişten günümüz mesela
burada senin burada bilmen gereken ne
biliyor musun İlk çağda coğrafya İlk
çağda coğrafya denildiği zaman aklına
nasıl isimler gelmesi lazım Edition eski
isimler Strabon değil mi Amasya Strabon
diyeceğiz buna stragon demek yok herodot
tes bu gibi isimleri duyduğunda hemen
ilk ilkler Gelecek aklına sana sorulursa
böyle sorulacak soru Çünkü
Aşağıdakilerden hangisi farklı bir
dönemde yaşayan coğrafyacı dır Ya da ilk
çağ coğrafyacıların biri değildir nasıl
anlayacaksın bunu ilk çağ coğrafyacıları
daha çok bakın Batlamyus Strabon
Aristoteles Tales Heredot erostan Bunlar
şimdi bunların bunlarla alakalı bazı
bilmemiz gereken şeyler var Mesela şunu
bilmemiz lazım batlamyus'un coğrafya
kılavuzu diye bir eseri var soruları
çözerken bu işine yarayacak coğrafya
kılavuzu Yunus Hoca gibi olanın
Batlamyus diyor bak
Batlamyus diyor Yunus var orada bak
Yunus
Batlamyus Batlamyus değil Batlamyus var
coğrafya kılavuzu coğrafya kılavuzu
Yunus Hoca gibi olan ne yapar batar sana
bir coğrafya kılavuzu dedi deinde a
coğrafya kılavuzu Yunus Hoca batam Yunus
Hoca gibi olan batar Batlamyus batarsın
coğrafya kılavuzun Yunus hoca gib ise
batmazsın Merak etmeyin Geçen sene yine
bir önceki sene olduğu gibi soruların
dör tanesi net bir şekilde soru tahmin
videosunda vurduk bu sene çözeceğim
sorularla da soruların çoğunu çözeceğim
göreceksiniz buraya kadar Tamam mıyız
Strabon Strabon Amasyalı Strabon
diyeceksiniz Strabon yok Sil onu
Amasyalı Strabon yaz onun tepesine
Amasyalı Strabon yaz Amasyalı Strabon
gerçekten de Amasya'da yaşamış şu an
bile gittiğinizde Amasya'da heykelini
görebilirsiniz bizim için önemli olan
Burası Strabon değil Amasya'da Strabon
diyeceksin buna Aristoteles yine var
Tales Heredot Bunlar diğer bilimlerde
olduğu gibi var bizim için burada önemli
olan eratos tenes eratos Enes Eray la
tost yiyen Enes eratos tenes demek yok
buna eratos tenes Eray la tost yiyen
Enes Eray la tost yiyen Enes hani böyle
elma düşüyordu ya başına Newton'un sonra
yarı çekimi buluyordu evreka buldum
diyordu O diyordu herhalde değil mi o
evrakı buldum diye Bunlar da böyle Eray
la tost yiyen enest Okulun bahçesinde
tost yerken Eray la tost yiyen Enes
buldum Neyi buldun coğrafyayı bul
coğrafya kelimesini coğrafyanın isim
babası kim Eray la tost yiyen Enes Eray
dinliyor musun beni ya da Enes Eray Enes
dinliyorsanız aşağı yorum atıyorsunuz
Ben de kalp atacağım sabitleyecek oradan
aklımıza gelecek Eray la tost diyen Enes
coğrafyanın isim babaları Sonra orta
Çağa geliyoruz Bak il çağda öyle bir
durum var şimdi Orta Çağda farklı bir
durum var Orta Çağ denildiğinde aklınıza
ilk ne gelir ilk önce şöyle Avrupa'daki
o skolastik düşünce kilisenin baskısı
karanlık Çağa gelir değil mi Ama Avrupa
için Karanlık Çağ Orası bizim için
Müslüman alemi için bilimin geliştiği
Çağ işte burada Müslüman Türk isimleri
görüyoruz hepsi Kaşkarlı Mahmut El
Biruni el-harezmi idrisi İbn batuda İbn
Haldun gibi isimleri gördüğünde
diyeceksin ki Aa Bunlar Müslümanlara
geçmiş bilim E o zaman ortaçağ Karan kar
çağda Avrupa karanlık çağda Ken bize
geçti diyeceksin bu isimleri duyduğunda
bunları orta Çağa koyacaksın ilk çağ
dediğinde ilk çağ ha hocam bunlar ilk
coğrafyacılar herodot aristotales gibi
isimleri duyduğunda ilk Çağa koyacaksın
hangi çağa hangi isimleri koyman
gerektiğinin mantığını da gösteriyorum
sana geldim buraya peki bu insanlar ne
yapmışlar bunların eserleri neler
eserlerini bilelim biz bakın el Harezmi
dediğinde birisi bize el Harezmi
buradaki kodlamam bak el Harezmi kitap
suret el Arz harz
Harezmi Harezmi var burada bak yani el
Harezmi Arzı arz Bunun içerisinde var
zaten buradan aklına gelecek kitap suret
el Arzı harz Harezmi'nin eseri bunu
yapman soruyu çözmeniz sağlayacak diğeri
idrisi kitap ür rü rüşandi İdris babayı
biliyorsunuz o çukur dizisinde değil mi
İdris baba nasıl yürüyordu rüşandi
üşeniyor kitap ürü şandi dediğinde bir
sana
üşendiği üşene üşene yürüyordu sildik
İbn batuta'nın Seyahatnamesi var İbn
Haldun mukaddime mukadderat İbn Haldun
İbn Haldun ya Haldun halun Haldun halun
halun nicedir halun nasıldır iyi misin
Ya uzun zamandır görüşmüyoruz Haldun
Haldun Haldun nasıl uzun zamandır
mukadderat ya mukaddime mukadderat ya
Nasıl olalım mukadderat işte ne yapalım
mukadderat kitap suret el Arzı harez mi
dedik K ya bu tarafa geldik el bir kanun
el maksudi maksadım kanun el maksudi
maksadım bir kanun yazmak biri sana
kanun el Maksud dediğin zaman maksadım
maksadım bir kanun yazmak kanun el
maksudi maksadım bir kanun yazmak Biruni
diyeceksin Kaşkarlı Mahmut'un Divanı
lügatı türkünü hepimiz edebiyat
dersinden biliyoruz durur Divanı Lügati
Türk Kaşkarlı Mahmut Evet orta çağdaki
coğrafyacılar mız da bunlar bu
kodlamalar hepsini test sorusu çözerken
nasıl rahatlıkla soruları çözmen
sağladığını göreceksin geldim buraya
yeni çağda coğrafya Yeni Çağ yeni çağda
artık çok farklı şeyler yaşanıyor Çünkü
Orta Çağda İslamiyet İslam dünyasına
geçmişti ya bilim İslam dünyası
zenginleşti vesaire orta çağı bitmeye
başlıyor düşünün şimdi Orta Çağ bitiyor
Ne olacak İslam dünyası zengin
Avrupalıların yeni yollar bulması lazım
yeni yollar için gemilere bilmesi lazım
Coğrafi keşiflerin olduğu Çağ burası
yeni çağda artık Avrupalılar coğrafi
keşiflere başlıyorlar ve bakın burada
yeni dünyaya geçiyorlar yeni dünyayı
yani Amerika'yı keşfediyorlar birçok
yere gidiyorlar Hindistan'a gidiyorlar
bunlarla alakalı bartelmi dias bartelmi
dias bartelmi dias Ümit burnunu
keşfediyor biri bize Ümit burnunu kim
keşfetmiştir dediği zaman Ümit burnunu
Ümit burnunu bardat telle kesmiş Ümit
burnunu barda telle kesmiş bartel mi
dias Ümit burnunu barda telle kesmiş
diyeceğiz Tamam gençler bakın ya bu
uyarıları yapmak istemiyorum ama
kodlamalar saçma gelecek sana geliyor
biliyorum ilk defa dinliyorsan lütfen
önyargılı olma bana karşı devam et
göreceksin Çok işine yarıyor ya Sadece
bir devam et ön yargılı olma Benden
nefret etmek zorunda da değilsin ben
keyfimden yapmıyorum bu kodlamaları ben
şunu da diyebilirim partel mi diyaz Ümit
burnunu keşfetmiştir deyip geçebilirim
böyle de yapabilirim istiyorum ki bu
derste öğren bu derste sadece sana
bilgiyi aktarmayı sana bilgiyi öğreteyim
kafanın içine yazayım hatta bilgiyi
öğren yöntemlerini göstermiş olayım sana
sonra sen kendin gidip tek tek yazarak
çalışarak öğrenmeye uğraşma o bilgiyi
sana yük olarak vermeyeyim git Sonra
çalış diye sen kendin Sen derste öğren
derste öğrenmiş ol burada bir zaman
kaybediyoruz değil mi burada öğrenmen
için yapıyoruz bunu öğretmenlik farklı
bir şeydir Her zaman dediğim gibi
anlatman çok farklı bir şeydir öğretmen
farklı bir şeydir öğretmen olmaya
çalışıyorum Lütfen kodlamaları saçma
deme sadece Dediklerime geldim christof
Colomb Kristof kumbu hepimiz biliyoruz
durur Amerika'nın keşfedilmesini
sağlayan kişi
Gama Hindistan'ı deniz yolu üzerinden
keşfeden kişi gençler bakın İpek ve
baharat yollarını öğreneceğiz ilerleyen
derslerimizde İpek ve baharat Yolları
osmanlın eline geçtiğinde avrupalılara
coğrafi keşiflerle denizlerden
Hindistan'a ulaşmaya çalışmışlar ve
Aslında İpek ve baharat yolunun önemini
kaybetmesine neden olan herif bu Vasco
de Gama Vasco de Gama bu herif Ümit
burnunu geçtikten sonra Hindistan'a
ulaşınca artık deniz yolu keşfedilmiş
oluyor Hindistan'ı deniz yolu üzerinden
ulaşan kişi Vasco de Gama ah ah ah Vasco
de Gama Hindistan'ı bulunca o İpek
baharat Yolları önemini kaybediyor Bu da
zengin oluyor viski artık ömrü boyunca
viski içiyor Ondan sonra zenginliği
bütün Ticaret yolunu keşfediyor adam
Katip Çelebi Cihan Numa Cihan Numa
Cihanlar biliyor musunuz siz bir hayvan
Cihan diye bir hayvan var biliyor
musunuz Katip Çelebi Katip kitap kitabı
bir açıyoruz içinden Cihan çıkıyor böyle
hayal edeceksin bunu kitabı bir açıyoruz
içinden ne çıkıyor Cihan çıkıyor çihan
çıkıyor Katip Çelebi Kitab içinden çihan
çıkıyor Evliya Çelebi'nin
Seyahatnamesi meşhurdur Edebiyattan da
biliyoruz bunu burada en değerli olan
bize
sorulacaksınız E sorulursa az sonra iki
tane coğrafyacı var Onları da
Göstereceğim sana Aslı Önemli olan Piri
reistir neden kitabı Bahriye eseri ve
bir de ceylan derisi üzerine çizilmiş
eseri var biri reisin ceylan derisi
üzerine çizilmiş dünya haritası
önemlidir bizim karşımıza çıkarsa ceylan
derisi üzerine çizilmiş kavramı çıkar
Bir de asıl bu çıkar kitabı Bahriye Piri
Reis biri bizi kitab-ı bahriyede
Bahar Bahar Bahar kitabı Bahriye Bahar
Pir eli Bahar diyeceksin kitab-ı Bahriye
Bahar pireli Bahar Piri Reis diyeceksin
soruyu tek kelimede yapacaksın gençler
bakın Eylül'de soru çözüm kampımız
başlayacak soru çözüm kampı başladığında
ben size o kodlamaları hatırlatarak O
soruların nasıl çözüldüğünü göstereceğim
ve o soru çözüm kampını çözerken Biz
aslında bir konu anlatım genel tekrarı
da yapacağız orada sorular üzerinden
sana resmen konu anlatımı da yapacağım
biliyorsunuz Ben soruları öyle çözdüm
geçtim değil konu anlatımı şeklinde de
yaparım O soruları çözerken aynı bir
konu anlatımı da yapacağım size tek tek
soruların hepsini şıkları yla beraber
bilgi öğrene öğrene ilerleyeceğiz Orada
göreceksin aylar geçecek bir aylar değil
2 ay geçecek 2 ay sonra o kampı
başladığımızda şöyle olacak p Race
diyeceğim sana kitabı Bahriye diyeceğim
sana Bahar pireli Baharda hocam
diyeceksin bütün hepsinin tekrarını
yapacağız orada ve geldik artık son
kısma Yeni Çağ dedik ve en son Yakın
çağda coğrafya asıl coğrafyanın coğrafya
olduğu yer burası Yakın çağda neden
coğrafya ın metodolojisi burada
oluşturuluyor coğrafya kavramını
öğrendik coğrafyanın ilkelerini öğrendik
coğrafyayı coğrafya bilim haline getiren
işte burası niye
metodolojiye sizinle beraber şurada ilk
çağdaki coğrafyalar coğrafyacılar daha
çok nasıl basit gözlemler ve tasvirler
üzerinden gidiyor ama buradaki coğrafya
artık modern coğrafyaya geçiyoruz burada
ve burada modern coğrafyayı kuranlar
kimler biliyor musunuz Alexander Von
humboldt ve Carl reiter gibi rutsel de
var mesela bunun gibi coğrafyacılar ve
bunlar genelde hep Almanya'dan
çıkıyorlar Alman coğrafyacılar Almanya
Almanya coğrafya için çok çok değerli
Evet modern coğrafya burada kuruluyor
Alman coğrafyacılar kuruyor modern
coğrafyayı bakın coğrafyanın
metodolojisi burada oluşturuluyor
coğrafyanın konuları ve bölümleri az
önce bölümleri ayırdık ya fiziki ve
beşeri coğrafya diye işte burada
oluşturuluyor ve burada ve burada fiziki
ve beşeri coğrafya diye iki tane
coğrafyacı öğreneceğiz o fiziki
coğrafyanın kurucusu işte Alexander Von
humboldt olacak beşeri coğrafyanın
kurucusu da şöyle yazalım beşeri
coğrafyanın kurucusu da Carl reiter
olacak ritter olacak ritter diyeceğim
ben buna riter diye okunuyor galiba
ritter diyeceğim niye ritter bitter
bitter çikolata bitter Çikolatayı kim
yiyecek insanlar yiyecek E o zaman Beşir
Beşir yiyecek beşeri coğrafyanın
kurucusu Carl ritter aynı zamanda Beşir
Çikolata yerken bitler Çikolata yerken
Karlı kar arabada sürüyormuş diğer
tarafta Alexander Von humb humboldt
demeyeceğiz biz buna Hüseyin Bolt
diyeceğiz e Hüseyin Bolt humboldt
Hüseyin Bolt Hüseyin Bolt Hüseyin bolt'u
biliyoruz koşucu Hüseyin Bolt E hocam
Fiziği çok güzeldi bu hüsein Bolt'un ya
o zaman Alexander Von Hum Bolt Hüseyin
Bolt hangi coğrafyanın kurucusu olacak
Fiziği çok güzelse fiziki coğrafyanın
kurucusu olacak evet Hüseyin Bolt Hum
Bolt ve bu Hüseyin Bolt Hüseyin Bolt
koşmayı çok sevmiyor mu bol bol koşmuş
kozmos koşmuş di
kim Hüseyin Bolt Alexander Von kumb
şimdi gençler coğrafyacılar kendi
arasında şöyle bir ayrım yaparlar aynı
coğrafya ikiye ayrılıyor ya
coğrafyacılar da kendi arasında ikiye
ayrılır fiziki coğrafyacılar fiziki
coğrafyayı sevenler beşeri coğrafyayı
sevenler fiziki coğrafyayı sevenler çok
fazla yok Genelde coğrafyacılar beşeri
coğrafyacı dır son zamanlarda Ben fiziki
coğrafya hastasıyım ama fiziki
coğrafyacıyım ben o yüzden Mesela ben
Alexander Von humboldt çuy humboldt çok
severim gitmiş adam Amerika'yı Güney
Amerika'yı dolaşmış amazonları dolaşmış
boydan boya Hatta orada soğuk s akıntısı
öğrendiniz ya dünya haritasında soğuk s
humboldt soğuk s akıntısı Buradan alıyor
ismini humboldt dan alıyor ismini benim
en sevdiğim coğrafyacı dır Alexander Von
humboldt Ben de açıkçası Humboldt'un
izinden gitmek istiyorum tabii ki onlar
gibi bir bilim olarak değil yapmayacağız
Biz bunu yaparken biraz daha modern
coğrafya olarak ilerlemek istiyorum
modern Coğrafyadan kastım ne Aslında
coğrafyanın değişmesi gerektiği
taraftarıyım ben yani modernize edilmesi
gerektiği taraftarıyım nedir bu şu an
gezi gezi işi geziler yapılan o geziler
oradaki coğrafyanın tanıtılması oradaki
coğrafyanın doğa ve insanın
etkileşiminin aktarılması Her biri bir
coğrafya değil mi Evet işte bunu yapmak
istiyorum Rota Türkiye projemizde bu
yaza başlayacağız inşallah sizi sınava
uğurlayacağız Ben de artık karavanı alıp
4 yılın sonunda karavanı almış olacağım
şu an 760.000 abonemiz var 1 milyona
ulaştığımızda karavana başlayacağız
ocakta karavanı araştırmalarına
başlayacağım sponsor bulurum İnşallah
yaza kadar eğitim alacağım karavan
olayını halledeceğim yazın sizi sınava
uğurladıktan sonra ben de karavanla
artık Türkiye'ye gezmeye başlayacağım 45
yılımı alacak büyük bir ihtimalle Bu
proje Her gittiğim şehirde bir ay
yaşayacağım o şehri hissedeceğim her
şeyini doğasını insanını beşeri
coğrafyasını doğal coğrafyasını hepsini
hissedeceğim ve Her gittiğim şehrin bir
rotasını çıkartacağım ve orada da Rota
coğrafya Rota Türkiye çıkmış olacak Bu
projede Bütün Türkiye'deki bütün
şehirlerin rotasını çıkartacağım ve o
zaman o zaman humboldt gibi bir
coğrafyacı olacağım geride 10 yıl 20 yıl
sonra geri dönüp baktığımda gerçek den
bir şey bırakmış olacağım şu an Tabii ki
değerli bir iş yapıyorum Size müfredat
müfredatı anlatıyorum ama coğrafya bu
değil bilimler bu olmamalı tarihi Ben
oradaki müfredatları sebep sonuçları
öğrenmemi bana bir faydası yok
coğrafyada burada bunca saçma sapan
bilgileri öğrenmem bana bir faydası yok
ama bu coğrafyadaki bilgileri o
şehirlerle beraber adapte edip modern
popüler coğrafya popüler coğrafyayı
ortaya koyduğumuz zaman işte o zaman ben
bir coğrafyacı olacağım Şu an bir
coğrafyacı falan değilim şu an bir
öğretmenim ama humboldt gibi
Türkiye'deki bütün şehirleri rotasını
çıkarttığımda gerçek bir coğrafya C
olacağım hayalim ve hedefim de benim de
hayalim ve hedefim de bu İnşallah Yaz
geldiğinde karavanımı alıp yollara
çıkmış olacağım bence Ben de carle
reader'ı ben çok fazla sevmiyorum ama
beşeri coğrafya beşeri coğrafya Öyle
bilgisayar başına geçişte İnsanlar pek
sevdiğim bir durum değil Evet
coğrafyanın coğrafyaya tarihi gelişimini
öğrendik Bir sonraki derste dünyanın
şekli ve hareketlerini öğreneceğiz
sizinle beraber ama oraya geçmeden önce
yeni dünya diye bir kavram var not
almamız gerekiyor Bunu Hani dedim ya
önemli noktaları not alacağız diye bunu
not al yeni dünya dadan kasıt ne işte
coğrafi keşiflerle beraber Eski dünya bu
tarafta Afrika Asya bütün Burası Eski
dünya şu taraf Amerika kısmı 1500'lü
yıllara kadar bilinmiyordu gençler
1500'lü yıllara kadar insanlar
Amerika'yı bilmiyordu Amerika'da yaşayan
var mıydı vardı orada astek Maya İnka
Medeniyetleri vardı öğreneceğiz orada
yaşayanlar vardı ama daha ilkel
kalmışlardı ama biz Eski dünya Bizler
orayı bilmiyorduk ne yaptık işte gemiler
pusulanın bulunması gemilerin sağlam
gemilerin olması Osmanlı'nın elinde İpek
ve baharat yollarının olması ticaret
yollarının kapalı olması avrupalıları
yeni yollar keşfetmeye yeni yollar
keşfedebilmek için de Hindistan'a
ulaşabilmek için yeni yollar
keşfedebilmek için de şöyle bir
çıkıyorlar Kristof Kolomb ve Ekibi
buradan geliyorlar buradaki adalara ve
buranın ilk önce anlamıyorlar Amerika
yeni bir kıta olduğunu Hindistan
sanıyorlar burayı ama sonradan
anlaşılıyor Amerika vespuci sonradan
buranın yeni bir kıta olduğunu anlıyor
ve Amerika keşfediliyor Amerika
keşfediliyor ve Amerika'dan yeni
dünyadan dünyaya domates patates o
dönemde tütün şu an içtiğiniz o saçma
sapan tütünler bile 1500'lü yıllardan
sonra dünyaya yayılıyor gençler yani
Amerika'nın keşfi bizi çok ciddi anlamda
eklemiştir yeni dünyanın nereye
söylendiğini de öğrendik mi öğrendik
Evet ya Yoruldum Yoruldum şöyle bir göz
göze gelelim Evet gençler seviliyorsunuz
kampımız inanıyorum Sizin için çok çok
faydalı olacak kampımız bittiğinde soru
çözümleriyle beraber de şöyle bir genel
tekrar niyetine soruları da çözdüğümüz
de sorulardan da bilgi öğrenip bütün
hepsini bitirdiğinizde Senin için çok
çok güzel verimli bir kamp olmuş olacak
inşallah 2024 tayfam Siz benim için çok
farklısınız Siz benim ilk mezun tayfam
olacaksınız bu sene de kısmet oldu
videolarımızı yeni ekipmanlarla size
yenilemeye kısmet oldu 23 yıldır eski
videolarımız vardı sizinle beraber
videolarımızı yeniliyoruz sizinle
beraber bu kampı bitireceğiz ben yollara
gideceğim Sizler de inşallah
üniversiteye gideceksiniz gittiğiniz
şehirlerde üniversitelerde buluşacağız
sizinle İnşallah seviliyorsunuz
enerjinizi hiçbir zaman düşürmeyin Bakın
bu kampımız ilk videosu Bizler hayal
imiz ve umutlarımız olmazsa yaşayamayız
Bak ben ne yaptım Bir Hayal için 4
yıldır çalışıyorum değil mi eski
mağaralarımız şu an iyi bir mağaradayız
manzaram falan da var artık Eskiden
mağara diyordum stüdyolara benim gelişim
aşamam takip ederseniz kanalda kötü
kameram yoktu sesli hiçbir şeyim yoktu
geliştim geliştim geliştim ve 4 yılın
sonunda Bir Hayal için mücadele ettim
her zaman mücadele ettim Ama bak Bir
Hayal için bir yola girdim Ama hayal
etmek yetmiyor oturdum çalıştım mücadele
ettim bazen çok çalıştım bazen Az
çalıştım Ama hep çalıştım emekleyerek de
olsa devam ettim bu hayatta kazananlar
sürekli devam edenler bazen koşarak
devam ederiz bazen emekleyerek devam
ederiz bazen moralimiz olmaz ama o
moralimiz olmadığı zamanlarda da
yürümemiz gerek işte moralinizin
olmadığı zamanlarda bile her zaman
hedefleriniz aklınıza gelsin Böyle
zamanlarda hedeflerinize Ulaştığınız
zamanları Hayal Ed Ben her zaman böyle
hayal ederim karavanla o şehirlerde
gezdiğim zamanları hayal ederim şöyle
bir toplanır Yunus kendine gel
hedeflerin için yavaş yavaş da olsa
devam etmeyi öğren derim Sen de en kötü
zamanında bile yavaş bile olsa
ilerliyorsa Senin önünde hiç kimse
duramaz Ben bir şeyi istiyorsam gider
alırım bir hedefi gerçekten istiyor
musun o zaman adam gibi çalışacaksın
gidip alacaksın Kimse Sana kimse sana
getirmeyecek o hedeflerini Sen az
çalışırsan Sen çalışmazsan o hedef için
uğraşan çok daha fazla çalışan gelir o
hedefi alır Ondan sonra deme Ben niye
yapamadım diye senden daha çok Çok
isteyen biri varmış Demek kimsenin
senden daha çok istemesine izin verme
Kimse benden daha çok istemedi bu zamana
Kimse benden daha çok istemedi ve Bugün
sadece iki 3 yıl içerisinde YouTube'un
en büyük coğrafya kanalı oldum ve bunu
tek başıma yap Deli gibi çalışarak yap
niye kimse benden daha fazla istemediği
Çünkü kimse benden daha fazla isteyemez
istese bile Ben daha fazla isterim
çalışır yaparım o zaman oturacaksın
senden daha fazla istemesine izin
vermeyeceksin kimsenin Sen daha fazla
isteyeceksin istemek yetmiyor oturup Sen
daha fazla çalışacaksın daha fazla
isteyip daha fazla çalışırsan kimse
önünde duramaz benim önümde kimse
duramadı kimse duramayacak bu saatten
sonra ben kendimi ancak bir gün istersem
bırakırım benim önümde kimse duramayacak
aynı Bunu söylemen lazım Her zaman benim
önümde kimse duramaz demen lazım
Kimsenin önünüzde duramayacağın güzel
bir yıl olsun deli gibi çalışacağınız
sonuna kadar çalışıp emeğinizin
karşılığını alacağınız bir yol olsun
seviliyorsunuz gençler Bir sonraki
derste görüşmek üzere